[Music]
your alter ego is she gonna burn Chico
Devine okay where is he
where does Chico Devine come out when I
believe Chico alone I had a daughter I
got a beautiful daughter now so had to
leave Chico alone she go along
Chico divided and got me kicked out of
Prince house you either freak but I'm a
big old freak I'm a really baby
paintballing freak so you became your
alter ego Chico Devine why you were at
Prince's house yeah he kicked me out
what we said you gotta go and as I
walked out the door I grabbed him by the
back of the neck and I said my father
loved when doves cry and I got this
close to Prince face and he was so
pretty had a little more right here a
little piece of my tongue came out
I got a beautiful daughter I can act
like that no more beautiful daughter and
also got a shotgun a shovel and an alibi
[Laughter]